I just don't buy it like when the girls
are like oh I didn't know I had no idea
like if you didn't know then your first
reaction when a girl pisses you off
wouldn't be to call her a I think
the women are blur in the line of the
word hoes or the women are in between
being a hoe and being married and that
space in between there is a dangerous
space for women to be because the whole
house like real hoes like for real that
know they come in and smashing everybody
in the room they don't give a like
you said they're proud hoes and they'll
let you know that they're a hoe and they
will make it clear that we hoes and we
are here twerking and then the girls who
are married like you at the other end of
the spectrum I have a different
perspective the women in the middle that
are single trying to get out of the
whole phase trying to get out of the
whole section that's why they blur the
line of like oh I'm not a hoe I'm just
dating oh no this is just my face this
is